currently only 19 out of 27 eu countries
provide some form of legal remedy to
victims of mass breaches of consumer
rights
meps adopted a law to allow eu consumers
to join forces to launch collective
action
parliament wants to make sustainable
practices a part of everyday life
that includes making it easier and
cheaper for consumers to repair products
which 77 of europeans would prefer to do
rather than replace them
every night more than seven hundred
thousand people in europe sleep on the
streets
an increase of seventy percent over the
last ten years
mep has called for stronger action to
put an end to homelessness in the eu
industry employs around 35 million
people in the eu
parliament wants the eu's industrial
strategy in the wake of the kovit 19
crisis to help
businesses recover and be part of a
transition to a digital
and carbon neutral economy
[Music]
40 of medicines marketed in the eu are
made in non-eu countries
parliament discussed how to make the eu
more self-sufficient when it comes to
medicine
and medical equipment so that everyone
can access affordable treatment at any
[Music]
time